I didn't sign up for demons okay I
signed up for go
my aunt sees dead people so my aunt aunt
lying to everyone in the family she
can't be lying to everyone she has some
cool stories though I tried to contact
my dead cat the next day I woke up put
on pants and there was cat hair on my
pants middle of the day I see this white
flash of light go in front of me is
there anyone here it's doing something
males freaked out is there a good spirit
Wow yeah yes yeah okay
can you tell us your name no oh my
missing in me oh my god are you are you
an animal yes I did talk to my count
ones why you animal we have to ask the
animals questions they stand hearing
like do they want to tree oh boy oh boy
oh no it's mad it's mad it wants bye bye
good bye
I'm starting to get a little concerned
about what I got myself into at first I
thought it was you but then I noticed
that your fingers are also like kind of
twitching and barely touching it that's
out of my god then it's got to be Jamie
I really just wanted to shake my fingers
off those two real is there anyone here
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm not even
touching this how is this even possible
seems like weird stuff is going on
whoever is here are you a good spirit
what's your name
it's going to be a fast no sudde you yes
this is Zeus I told you it was this this
can you tell us what year you died six
six six nine six did you die in 1996
1896 1796 okay we're going to something
why must be yes that's yes why we still
don't know if it's a good or a bad
spirit yeah
I never answered well regret this I
don't think we should ask whether it's a
bad spirit er I would like to know if it
is I don't want our spirit
I don't want it out c0 are you a good
spirit no no no no no no no no no where
are we going Knight is bad if everyone
promises that they weren't pushing it I
like pinky promise triple pinky promise
cool then goodbye
absolutely not that did not just happen
the more I told myself it's not real
don't believe it it's not that didn't
really happen it's like the more freaked
out I got I don't even know how to
explain what just happened which must
mean something about it is real I'm so
scared